A liquid medication used to always come in a
bottle and you had to pour your dose with a
steady hand into a spoon.
Today, many medications and supplements come
inside small food, safe casings that are easy
to swallow and portable.
Soft gel capsules.
Many types of products come in gel capsules
from prescription drugs to health supplements
such as fish oils.
Many of these medicine fills go bad if
exposed to oxygen.
So the gel cap, besides being convenient,
also serves as a protective barrier.
Every ingredient in both the gel cap and the
medicine fill inside undergoes extensive
testing for purity.
The first test phase checks for bacterial
contamination.
Lab technicians dissolve the ingredient in
solution.
Apply it to a food source in a petri dish,
then incubate the dish for 72 hours to
encourage any existing bacteria to grow.
Then they draw samples and examine them
under a microscope.
If those samples are bacteria free, the
ingredient moves onto the second phase of
testing, which checks for contaminants such
as lead, arsenic, mercury and cadmium.
This machine, called a spectrometer, injects
the ingredient solution into a plasma flame.
Then, by reading the changes in light
wavelengths, analyzes the chemical
composition. If the ingredient is
contaminant free, it gets the go ahead.
The gel cap is made entirely of natural
ingredients gelatin derived from beef bones,
palm oil, glycerin and purified water.
The proportions are top secret.
An industrial blender combines the three
ingredients to a uniform.
Consistency then heats the mixture to 80°C.
A vacuum sucks out the air bubbles.
As this now ready gel material flows into a
holding tank.
Simultaneously, they prepare the medicine
fill, in this case vitamin D.
They combine it with soybean oil to adjust
the potency to the specified strength.
Meanwhile, they maintain the gel cap
material in the holding tank at 60°C to
prevent it from prematurely solidifying.
Even the hose leaving that tank is wrapped
in heater tape to keep the gel liquid a
separate hose. Feeds the vitamin D solution
from another holding tank down to the
production floor as well.
This hose doesn't require heating because
vitamin D and soybean oil don't solidify when
cool. On the production line, two stations
simultaneously spread a thin layer of molten
gel across a cooling drum.
The gel hardens into a solid yet malleable
sheet about the thickness of cardboard.
Each sheet passes over a rotating die with
capsule shaped cavities just before the two
gel sheets come together.
Pumps inject the required quantity of
vitamin D solution into each cavity.
The pressure pushing the gelatin into the
cavity at the same time the machine heats the
gel sheets so that when they meet, they
adhere to each other, forming full capsules
with the vitamin D solution sealed inside.
In the final second, the dies sharp edges
slice the gel caps free and they fall to a
conveyor belt below.
At this point, the filled gel caps contain a
fair bit of moisture, so they're quite soft.
If they'd lay on a surface too long, they'd
flatten.
So the conveyor belt whisks them very
quickly into a rotating drum where they
tumble in slightly cool, dry air for about
three hours.
This removes enough moisture to make the gel
caps hard enough to lie on a surface without
flattening. After exiting the gel, caps move
into a second dryer where spread out on
trays. This time they dry for about 36
hours.
After that, the gel caps are hard enough to
be safely packaged.
The gel caps, the ones being packaged here,
contain flax oil, travel down a series of
vibrating plates which progressively line
them up in single file.
As they pass by, electronic eyes count out
the number of capsules per bottle, triggering
the filling mechanism to collect that
quantity and release it into an empty bottle.
The next station applies a plastic twist
cap.
Then the bottles move onward, each one
plowing directly into the center of an
adhesive backed label, which rollers then
apply around the sides before shipping The
quality control lab tests random samples
from the production batch to verify that the
gel caps meet all specifications.
It's a playground staple, a stationary ride
on cartoon animal that bounces up and down
and rocks back and forth courtesy of a huge
spring underneath secured into the ground.
The bouncy coil base is what gives this type
of playground equipment its name.
A Spring Rider.
The Spring Rider is a playground favorite to
withstand years of rambunctious riders.
It has to be solid and durable.
Yet for a toddler to be able to rock back
and forth, it can't be too heavy.
That's why the spring is made of thick steel
and the animal of lightweight aluminum.
That sand core is comprised of two halves,
each made with an aluminum mold duct shaped.
In this case, workers fill it with sand and
adhesive mix that sets into a solid block.
They insert several steel support rods, fill
to the top and even out the surface, then
expose two hooks they'll grab to extract the
core half once the sand hardens in about 20
minutes. Meanwhile, other workers use an
aluminum pattern to make each half of the
duct casting mold.
After applying a powder release agent to
prevent sticking, they cover the pattern with
a sieved mixture of sand and clay.
They mount a frame around the pattern to
contain the sand as they add more and more
repeatedly packing it down in all areas with
a pneumatic ramming tool.
Then they removed the frame and cover the
sand with a wooden board.
This provides a hard surface for the press,
which now applies the weight of about four
mid-size SUVs.
Then they flip the mold over and remove the
pattern which formed the mold cavity.
The sand is now so firmly compacted that it
holds the shape.
One half of the sand mold has channels
through which the molten metal will flow into
the cavity. Workers now position several six
millimeter thick foam spacers in the cavity
and place half of the core on top of them.
The spacers elevate the core, creating a six
millimeter cavity between core and mold.
The other half of the core goes on top.
After placing spacers on top of that to
create a six millimeter gap on this side as
well, they carefully lower the other half of
the sand mold.
Now they're ready to cast the duck.
The melting point of aluminum is 590°C.
However, they heat it much higher to 760
degrees, so it'll flow faster and fill the
entire cavity before beginning to solidify.
They pour the metal through holes on top.
It flows through the runners into the mold
cavity, which is that six millimeter gap
surrounding the duck shaped core.
About 20 minutes later, the metal has cooled
and solidified.
They break the mold apart on a vibrating
sieve, releasing the aluminum duck and
shaking out the core sand through a hole at
the bottom of the duck.
After cutting off excess aluminum that
hardened in the runners, they grind down the
seam, which formed in between the two halves
of the mold.
Next, they weld on aluminum handles for the
child to grip when riding.
These handles are cast in sand molds just
like the duck.
Workers grind down the weld and any sharp
edges, making the entire surface nice and
smooth. Next.
A coat of polyester powder in bright rubber
ducky.
Yellow. Then a 20 minute trip through an
oven to bake the coating, making it ultra
durable. Now delicately airbrushed with a
urethane enamel paint the details that bring
Mr. Duck to life.
His feet, wings, bill and eyes.
The thick coil that makes this a spring
rider is made of a flexible type of steel.
They bolt a steel spacer plate to it.
Then hide the bolts under an aluminum cover.
After attaching a footrest steel again, they
bolt the duct to the plate.
All these parts like the duck are painted
with baked on polyester coating.
The spring bolts to a concrete block buried
underground.
Ducky and friends are designed to withstand
even the harshest winters, letting children
enjoy a little spring all year round.